so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Batman and Superman
teaming up to fight the undead and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of the
story you'll have had a little bit of
fun and at the very least you might find
this a series worth checking out so
Batman is Superman teaming up to fight
the undead actually comes out of a
series called Batman confidential and
what this was was a series of
publications released between 2006 and
2011 and served to provide short stories
from various writers and artists as a
proving ground to demonstrate their art
and storytelling but to also provide
these stories as an explanation of
Batman's exploits following the events
of Batman year one by Frank Miller which
rebooted his origins after crisis on
Infinite Earths and established the
various foes and allies that he
discovered and who would eventually
become mainstays in his comics written
by Kevin Van Hook and drawn by Tom
Mandrake Batman vs the undead like all
of the Batman confidential stories is
self-contained and initially opens with
Bruce Wayne and New Orleans Louisiana
being in the city due to the unveiling
of a Wayne foundation Children's
Hospital while Bruce Wayne gives his
speech the story continues his monologue
but also shows someone smashing into one
of the family tombs and removing a
casket with a perfectly preserved body
inside transitioning to later in the
night Bruce Wayne reveals that in
addition to attending the ceremony for
the Wayne Foundation Children's Hospital
he's also tracking a man named Herbert
Combs in a sidetrack for a second
Herbert Combs is indicated to have been
an inmate that escaped Arkham Asylum at
some point but he only appears in this
series and so he's largely a one-off
created explicitly for this miniseries
now while monitoring the city and
looking for a place to start
Batman notices another person jumping
from the rooftops onto the streets below
now picking up with a meeting between
Herbert Combs and a museum curator named
geezer Ellie the two of them are
discussing a business arrangement in
which Herbert appears to be funding the
curators Museum as user Elie explains he
had collected multiple corpses of
deceased criminals from Germany in other
parts of the world after which he
preserved and put them on display as a
kind of grotesque Museum to entertain
the uneducated members of the city as an
example one of the specimens collected
is the corpse of a 3,000 year old timber
wolf from northern Mexico some of the
other specimens include a Mexican family
that was discovered deceased while
sitting in an upright position
indicating
that they had died suddenly with no
known causes however in the midst of
continuing his explanation of the
exhibits Herbert combs uses an
extendable knife to stab geezer le
through the back of the head killing him
in the process now transitioning back to
Batman in his pursuit of the unnamed man
after catching up with him we learned
that this is someone named Demeter as
another character created and introduced
in this story Demeter is a vampire who
is part of the situation for unknown
reasons now the conversation between
Batman and Demeter indicates that the
two of them had met before in that Bruce
Wayne asks if Demeter has been keeping
his thirst under control but as far as
my research is turned up there's no
indication that Demeter has ever been an
extended part of Batman's continuity but
regardless the purpose behind Demeter
being here is that like Bruce he's been
tracking Herbert Combs since his release
from Arkham from here the insanity of
Combs becomes apparent when the story
shows him looking through a stack of
papers while talking with someone named
Andy and discussing his intention to
beef up the security of the museum and
effectively take it over during a study
of the schematics a silent alarm is
triggered by both Batman and Demeter
after which is revealed that Andy is
dead and hanging on the wall
removing Andy's head from his body combs
begins to perform a ritual in which he
seems to be returning the souls of the
dead to their decayed bodies in the
museum as a result while Batman and
Demeter make their way through the
building in their search for combs the
two are suddenly set upon by multiple
zombies both human and animal working
together and taking them down almost
immediately it's revealed that these
undead were only animated temporarily
most likely as a distraction for comes
to make his escape at the same time
because Demeter is a vampire and with
the Sun rising in the next several
minutes in order to keep from suffering
exposure and possibly dying as a result
he leaves Batman to deal with combs
until night falls and he can assist once
more now jumping back to combs we find
him in the Bayou of Louisiana visiting a
local voodoo priest named mama Ossie Lee
according to the conversation between
the two mama Azalea had provided combs
with the means to resurrect the dead and
the achievement that he had used was
provided as a sample of sorts and that
he wouldn't resurrect an army but bring
back enough to prove that mama azalea's
magic was legitimate switching back to
Batman as he investigates the museum
office of the now deceased geezer le he
discovers that in addition to both
himself
and combs conversing by email comes had
been using their connection to gain
access to mama easily while searching
for combs during the time in which he
was performing the enchantment grease
reveals that he had overheard the name
is Ely combined with the name Eva while
the name is Ely is meaningless the name
Aoife itself means the goddess of
vengeance and destruction indicating
that when the two were put together it
invokes the goddess Aoife as a means to
enhance the powers of his Ely allowing
for the resurrection of an army of the
Dead and so because this would present a
circumstance beyond his ability to deal
with on his own while maintaining his
covers Bruce Wayne during a gala of
sorts in the French Quarter Batman takes
a moment to contact Clark Kent informing
him that the transpiring events are more
than he can handle on his own agreeing
to meet him Clark states that he can fly
down to Louisiana the following day in
order to help in dealing with the
problem now joining back with Demeter we
find him traveling to a local jail
holding a friend named Janko who suffers
from like Anthropy also known as being a
werewolf because Batman is aware of the
company that Demeter keeps his detective
work has led him to the conclusion that
as a vampire Demeter would inevitably
seek out Janko for the purpose of
recruiting aid in the same capacity that
Batman had recruited Superman
transitioning to the inside of the jail
because Janko loses self control
whenever he's exposed to the full moon
and because tonight is a full moon night
during his incarceration he transforms
into a werewolf ripping open the cell
door and preparing to attack the guard
the scene is met by both Demeter his
girlfriend and Batman who band together
for the purpose of bringing Jenko under
their control however the three fail to
succeed as he jumps out of a window
which reveals that the building is being
set upon by a series of zombies teaming
up with Demeter and Janko Batman does
what he can to take the zombies head on
without being infected in the process at
the same time though Batman also gives
us some perspective of the group that
he's fighting with from his view the
afflictions of vampirism of Demeter and
the lycanthropy of Janko are fortunate
was struggle to maintain their composure
during the intense situation unfolding
meaning that they're walking a knife's
edge with the potential of falling over
the edge and becoming just as dangerous
as the enemies they face however the
concern of Batman is ass waged when
Superman arrives to fight alongside
everyone a problem arises though in that
during the battle with this
bobby's is revealed the Superman's
powers of heat vision are useless
against the zombies for two reasons the
first is because damage to their
physical bodies does not stop a function
of their brain and the second is that
the zombies are magically protected
meaning a Superman cannot damage magic
using a strength Clark's smashes the
ground and opens a fissure which
swallows a zombies as they mindlessly
walk forward and into the ravine in
addition to this because Batman has seen
Demeter uses magic before he calls on
Demeter to use his belief in voodoo as a
way to clear out the zombie horde
agreeing to do so after being screamed
at by Batman and Superman Demeter's use
of voodoo magic cuts a connection
between combs and the zombies once a
conflict is finished though it's
discovered that Demeter's girlfriend Liv
has been kidnapped once dr. fate appears
and informs a group that they have to
travel to a place called corto Maltese a
small island off the coast of South
America and an effort to get her back
furthermore dr. fate informs Superman
that because his powers are useless
against magic and that his laser vision
super-strength and various other
abilities can be nullified by sorcery at
the end of all of this he will end up
joining the dead but also the doctor
fate himself cannot join the group and
their efforts to rescue live as his
brand of magic is incapable of
overcoming or neutralizing the various
black magics being used now
transitioning to corto Maltese we join
mama as alien combs as they work to
resurrect the dead as she explains those
who had died recently are relatively
easy to resurrect and the hardest ones
to bring back are those who have died a
long time ago reviewing these particular
individuals we find that the dead dating
all the way back to the soldiers of the
famed conquistadors of Hernan Cortes are
being resurrected along with all manner
of beasts however the true power of
black magic that mama is Elia is calling
upon comes from the newly dead something
that she gains by sacrificing a young
man to a pit full of snakes organizing a
plan for themselves we join Batman as he
arrives in the middle of the ritual and
begins attacking the various zombies but
while this happens mama as eally has
Batman distracted and a fire circle as
established keeping Batman out but
allowing them to continue picking up
with both Superman and Demeter we find
him traveling to another location within
corto Maltese to visit a witch named
Geneva who was the individual that seems
to a provided Demeter
the various forms of magic that he
currently uses establishing that mama is
Ely is using the cemetery as a way to
resurrect zombies in order to keep
Batman and his allies away the true
motives of our actions are to bring back
a powerful shaman who can raise an army
of the dead for the purpose of world
domination
led by calms and the only way to counter
the magic is to provide a powerful being
of their own who can defeat the shaman
in question and so with Batman having
retreated due to his inability to
penetrate the fire circle the story
focuses on mama Izzi lien Combs several
hours later as a to succeed in digging
up the shaman from A Grave
deep in the ground while liz is made to
watch the events unfold during the
resurrection process were told that for
his entire adult life Herbert Combs has
dedicated his time to focusing on his
infatuation with the dead for him the
possibility of becoming the ruler of the
world by way of controlling an army of
the Dead has been the core of everything
he's been working for since his
obsession began and while he allows
himself a brief moment of celebration at
the eleventh hour we learned that this
mummy is not wrapping the body of a
long-dead shaman and instead it's
wrapping Superman himself while this
line of logic is flimsy to say the least
with Batman making his move by
confronting Herbert Combs alongside
Geneva and Demeter is revealed that
Geneva uses white magic which seems to
be stronger than mama as Ely and that
she was the one that had placed Superman
into the ground to impersonate the
shaman furthermore with mama as Ely
refusing to accept death at the hands of
Geneva or anyone else she invokes
emulation sacrificing herself in the
process proclaiming as she will join the
goddess of destruction and vengeance and
so as the story comes to an end where
Superman offers to fly Batman back to
Gotham on his way to taking Herbert
Combs to prison after Bruce declines
intending to take the Wayne Foundation
Jett back home Superman comments that
Batman should not spend too long in this
place something that's compounded on
when Batman reveals that the situation
of zombies monsters and voodoo magic has
pushed his sanity to its breaking points
and that spending too much time here
would set him over the edge well that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and I will catch you
guys later
peace